fun fact of the day uh you know michael
buffer
no let's get ready to oh yeah of course
i do yeah yeah yeah
um obviously but not obviously in 1982
he started his career as a ring
announcer
as everyone may or may not know but he's
the guy that says let's get ready to
rumble
um and he trademark he earned five
thousand pounds per show five thousand
dollars rather per show
up until 1992 where he trademarked the
phrase let's get ready to rumble
and now in 2020 since it's been
trademarked it's worth
he's worth 400 million dollars that's
impossible
just say something else in it because
i'm not paying him just so i can say
that
people are selling it you've sold the
rights to like video games tvs movies
blah blah blah
even like for people that not
necessarily just live in the uk but if
you know charlie sloth
um he's a dj and like a host a radio
host
when he's um got people on his show to
start
rapping and stuff the first thing he
puts on his let's get ready to run
i'll swear yeah fire in the booth
yeah he does that so yeah he's
trademarked he's got p bro
400 million millions just because he
said 20 20.
but he's in 1982 that's a long last time
but his brother does the same thing do
you know that i never knew that
bruce buffer oh he does it for the ufc
no way yeah yeah yeah he's the don that
does it for you i think boost buff is
more alive though why is that just in
terms of hype okay
it's just like when he when he sets it
up does he doesn't say the same thing he
didn't say let's get right to rumble now
he says like it's time
he says it's time okay so he'll say
he'll announce the don
so red corner blue corner and then
everyone is a little bit excited and
he's like and
time and bro i get hyped i'm like this
scrap
let's scrap he's sick yeah bruce
buffer's live
i'm a big fan but yeah that's he's never
going to get the kind of p his brother's
got oh never in a million years
but fair play though 400 mil he coined
it and that's
it and he used to get paid 5k a turn how
do you even become a regular
ringer i don't have the skills nor the
knowledge to answer that question
bro i would i would trip up
every single time the pressure would be
a lot for me i would trip up i would
mess with anyone's name
i'll mess up everyone i will say the
different wrong colors
wrong color shorts everything for him i
don't know what he's approaching i don't
know what
gym you're fighting out of what